Some compounds smell really good.
Because of the chemicals they contain, cinnamon
and vanilla have a pleasant odor that you
might call aromatic.
When an organic chemist uses this word, they’re
likely referring to “aromaticity,” which
is a special feature of some compounds.
Now, I don’t want to imply that all molecules
with aromaticity smell good; pyridine is an
aromatic compound with an unpleasant, fish-like
odor, and this aromatic pyridine salt has
no scent at all.
Additionally, compounds that are not aromatic
can have strong odors.
So if aromaticity isn’t tied to smell, how
can we tell if a compound is aromatic?
Let’s begin by talking about benzene, the
classical example of an aromatic compound.
We can draw a resonance form for benzene where
it looks like the double bonds have moved.
But this isn’t the whole story at all.
There is a continuous system of p-orbitals
above and below the ring.
The electrons are actually delocalized around
the ring, circling around the pi system.
An electron density map of benzene shows red
“hot spots” of electron density where
the pi electrons are concentrated.
Although some benzene representations seem
to have alternating single and double bonds,
each bond is 1.39 Å long, which is between
the length of a carbon-carbon double and single
bond.
This is due to the delocalization of electrons
we discussed, and it makes aromatic compounds
rather stable.
To be aromatic, a cyclic compound must have
a continuous pi system, and be planar.
It must also satisfy Huckel’s rule, having
4n+2 electrons in the pi system, where n is
zero or a small, positive number.
Now, ompounds that contain 4n electrons in
the pi system are particularly unstable, and
are referred to as antiaromatic.
We need to be able to identify aromatic compounds
because they have unique reactivity.
When an alkene is treated with bromine, the
double bond acts as a nucleophile, forming
a cation that is attacked by Br minus.
The end result is addition of Br2 across the
double bond.
When benzene is treated with bromine, an iron
catalyst is required because of benzene’s
stability.
Benzene attacks bromine; but, Br minus does
not add to the cation.
The stability gained by the compound becoming
aromatic again is so great that the intermediate
is deprotonated instead, resulting in the
addition of just one bromine atom.
Let’s explore some more examples of aromatic
compounds.
When n=0, there are two electrons in the pi
system, and an example is the cyclopropenyl
cation.
If n=1, there are six electrons in the pi
system, and benzene and pyridine are examples.
Pyridine is a weak base, because it has a
lone pair that does not participate in the
pi system.
It sticks out perpendicular, or orthogonal,
to the pi electrons.
Orthogonal lone pairs can make bonds without
disrupting aromaticity.
So, this methyl-substituted pyridinium ion,
like the pyridine salt we saw earlier, is
also aromatic.
Pyrimidine is another example.
It has two orthogonal lone pairs and three
double bonds in the ring making up the pi
system.
Pyrimidine rings are very important because
they make up your DNA.
The cyclopentadienyl anion is an aromatic
5-membered ring.
The negative charge on carbon is a lone pair
that can participate in the pi system.
Building on this, pyrrole is also an aromatic
compound.
At first glance, it appears that there are
only 4 pi electrons.
However, there is a lone pair on nitrogen
that can participate in the pi system.
Furan is also aromatic because one of the
oxygen lone pairs contributes.
Geometrically, the second lone pair can’t
join, so we have 6 pi electrons again here.
This positively charged seven-membered ring
is also aromatic.
The carbocation is trigonal planar; the empty
p orbital occupies the space above and below
the ring, making a continuous pi system.
When we get into 10 electron pi systems, things
get a little more complicated.
Cyclodecapentaene fits most of our criteria
for aromaticity.
It satisfies Huckel’s rule, and is cyclic
with a continuous pi system.
However, in order to be flat, it would need
to have bond angles of 144 degrees, which
is far from the normal bond angle for an sp2
hybridized carbon–carbon bond, so the strain
overcomes any aromatic stabilization, and
this molecule bends.
Ok, so what if we introduce some trans double
bonds to relieve the angle strain?
We run into a different problem here.
Because the H-atoms are now facing inward
toward each other, they have steric clash
and this molecule is not planar either.
But, if the H atoms are replaced with a methylene
bridge, the steric hindrance is eliminated,
and this molecule is aromatic.
Returning to our chart, this eight-membered
ring with two nitrogen atoms is another example
of a 10-pi electron aromatic compound.
Because both nitrogen lone pairs are needed
to complete the pi system, they have to be
substituted with electron donating groups;
if the groups are too electron withdrawing,
the lone pairs are pulled out of the pi system.
The molecule twists because aromatic stabilization
can no longer overcome steric strain.
This 9-membered ring is also aromatic, again
provided that the nitrogen is substituted
with electron donating groups and can contribute
to the pi system.